Will you please stop chasing clients?
Clients suck. They want to outsource you
for as cheaply as possible and they want
to replace you as soon as possible with
a $50 AI tool. Why not instead of client
work switch over to creator work where
you can write and create content online
for something you're passionate about
and then write those people an email, a
daily email where then you can sell
courses, cohorts, communities, anything
about a passionate subject you love and
you can build this business all yourself
online. It's never been easier. We've
never had access to the tools that we
have today. Instead of you worrying
about getting clients, your clients
should be worried about never getting
the most creative incredible people
because they're building their own
thing. I want you to go build your own
thing.